all right guys
bang bang got isaiah here with me what's
going on man nothing much man
always good to see you obviously miami i
feel like you've been coming to miami
more often now
definitely every time i can and and
really with uh mayor suarez doing the
new stuff
it's easier now bitcoin is all welcome
so i'm coming he he clearly stated he
wants miami to be bitcoin city
oh yeah and i feel like he's actually
taking steps towards it and i've seen it
everywhere i've seen
bitcoin stickers bitcoin people accept
it i mean he has the white paper on the
website come on man i mean he really
wants this to come through so
definitely special uh place i come every
time i can so people have forgotten that
he did that he took the
satoshi's white paper and he put it on
the city of miami's
website exactly and it's just sitting
there and everybody can view it
and he even has a plan for people to get
paid in bitcoin he has a you know ftx
has the name of the miami heat i mean
he's going all the way so yeah
definitely
a beautiful place to come for bitcoin is
especially now all right so what's
not so beautiful is a green piece uh
recently said they're not going to
accept bitcoin anymore and you had this
epic rant so
just tell what happened and what are
your thoughts oh yeah well
i think it was a culmination of seeing
all of this coordinated
uh journalists and and people in the
media talking about the environment
with bitcoin this is an old argument i
mean this was 2017 when i first saw that
um and we've even seen the argument
against amazon
because of the environment back in 99.
so it's just an old argument i think uh
the people who are in power who want
that
environmental money from the epa or from
the government they have to keep it
going
bitcoin's just the new target it's a new
kid on the block they're saying
in greenpeace in particular when they
said they're not accepting it i was like
why are you
you know basically succumbing to the
environmental pressure but
that's who pays them so uh you know you
kind of have to go with it
and the rant the only reason it was kind
of epic it was like i said a culmination
of just seeing i was like i know
these people are working together i mean
who who sent the email out where all
these people
all of a sudden they're talking about
the environment do you think that
they're actually like colluding with
each other like there's like a secret
meeting and they all are getting on the
conference call and they're like i don't
know if it's a secret meeting but it's
different
it's different media places and i think
they may send out an email like hey this
may be the thing to talk about
um because it happened right in a row it
was like six or seven media stories i
saw within a two week span
and then greepings comes out they're not
accepting it and i'm like okay well
um they're so big you know it may it you
know may impact people
i've seen people even say i don't want
to buy bitcoin because it may impact the
environment i was like this
just popped up out of nowhere so
greenpeace
them doing it um you know that's why
that rant was what it was but
at the end of the day i just think they
were scared of whatever ramifications
may come from it and then
they'll figure it out later i actually
don't think that there's like a secret
meeting or like
a conference call but what i do think is
that they're all colluding
with each other because there's a lack
of original thinking that goes on inside
these large organizations
what they see is they see you know let
me go on uh such and such
uh media outlets website oh look their p
their hit piece on bitcoin's energy
consumption
is their number one article we don't
have one of those we should go write an
article
and they task somebody and they say hey
go write this and
in some cases the journalists may not
even know why they're being
assigned something right but also
there's some times where literally these
idiots are sitting there waiting to
write the hit piece right they're like
oh the price fell finally i can write it
not look like an idiot
and so i think that it it's um it
definitely
feels like there was a big wave uh
and nobody is going to explain
in any um kind of uh competent way
that anything changes the information as
to why all of a sudden this is an issue
but
it wasn't an issue six weeks ago or six
months ago and they accept
the petrol dollar it's in the name
that's way more energy
inefficient than bitcoin and we've
already have we already have the stats
it's not even it's a mute point at this
point i mean we already know bitcoin
doesn't use anywhere as much uh
energy consumption as gold as banks as
pretty much anything i mean i think
christmas lights uses more energy
consumption than bitcoin at this point
so
uh it's a new point and i think it is
colluded simply because of that it's an
argument that
is really just to get people to not do
it and that may be the influence on elon
musk
you know maybe switch it switching his
uh position
um i don't did he switch though but
that's what i said i don't i didn't
think that was forever i think he just
said it
and then he realized you know uh maybe
we can solve it with michael saylor to
have him meetings
bitcoin mining council so i don't know
all of this stuff coming at the same
time it seems like there's something
going on as far as uh
my guess solution uh the fact that tesla
did not sell any cars for bitcoin
probably played into some of this right
which by the way means that bitcoins are
smart
right uh but two is that uh
how do you stop taking the payments and
not have to answer the question as to
why you're not accepting it
oh this is a kind of a good cop-out but
they didn't sell any bitcoin it'll be
very interesting to see if they
bought more when the price fell so
aggressively oh yeah well i think
long-term plan they're going to use
their their energy
at some point to mine bitcoin i think
that's the ultimate plan it's just all
this stuff in between is just
just noise um and i think because he has
teamed up with michael saylor or they
had that meeting
and we have seen what their discussions
are about you know it's only 10 of the
mining it's not like
it's a big thing but the fact that they
are being transparent trying to do these
things
i think they're just trying to succumb
as well but it's it's a good thing right
i mean i guess you
want to try and make it as as energy
efficient as possible would you
renewable energy
what did you think of the mining council
um at first you know it was like a shock
like why would you even talk to elon
he's not even
you know he doesn't mind um but the
miners that did join they were reputable
and the people that were there they you
know had a discussion but it's nothing
wrong with a discussion i mean
it's not a big thing and i think a lot
of people were mad at first again
because they didn't look into it but
again it's only 10 of the miners in the
world
and they already do that they are
they're already transparent they already
give out the information
so um you know the net-net of it i think
is just uh
a meeting they had and we'll see what
comes of it i i forget who said it
um but i saw somebody i think maybe from
galaxy or whatever
uh came out and said look maybe the word
gives this like feeling of like oh you
have to come to us and we as the council
will
uh will approve or make decisions uh and
instead if they had said association
right just by changing the the
nomenclature all of a sudden the people
like ah cool okay well of course the
miners have an association you know
to to whatever and so uh when i saw that
i was like man that's a really good
point
obviously they're gonna change the name
but they they didn't change the name
they kept that as counseling
and and people said it felt segwitish
like it felt like uh a
pushback but at the end of the day again
segwit was like a
you know you are not saturday night this
is sort of like it's just a meeting it
wasn't a
backroom uh thing so you know not not
really bad net net of it but we'll see
what
it's one of the funny things uh to me in
the bitcoin world where there's a fine
line right like
i think most people in bitcoin this is
over generalization but
most people uh they believe in free
speech they believe in freedom of
association
right they believe in the ability for if
you want to go have a meeting go have a
meeting you want to go and do something
go do it right whatever
uh but the free market will kind of take
over the social construct all that kind
of stuff
by the way if you go and you do
something stupid you can't be upset then
if somebody calls you stupid for doing
it right
um but at the same time uh
there's been examples in history where
people have had the meeting
and they became a threat or they
attacked bitcoin and the network and all
this stuff and so
uh it's a balance right between hey just
because you have a meeting that's okay
right and next time i have whatever
meetings you want but if you come
you know if you come at the king you
best not miss that's not this exactly
shout out to the wire because again when
as michael steele would say the cyber
horn is
on you you better be able to defend
yourself and we self-regulate we
basically those people that were against
it or you know against it happening
we kind of kicked them out the community
i mean it's just how we do and i think
it's healthy
as a marketplace of ideas yeah like you
just said freethinkers and bitcoin
everybody's free to argue and you know
somebody that was in computer science
like myself
that's how you get good products they
literally start off by critiquing you
from top you don't get praised until
you're billionaire like nobody cares
they're like yeah this is trash and this
sucks
so it keeps you sharp keeps you going i
think bitcoins do that awesome
mark andreessen recently gave this
interview and i'm gonna paraphrase the
the quote that he
uh said in it but he said listen you
know for 2 500 years
we have found that the only way to get
progress from like the default state of
misery and just uh despair is
to be able to freely think right
and argue right those things are
actually what create the progress
not okay nobody do anything because when
you have a world of nobody do anything
you get no progress still yeah and it's
boring i mean
i mean i even in bitcoin i look for
people to argue with sort of just
to keep it fun because when it's an echo
chamber of ideas it's like all right we
all agree
whatever but you're right yep
marketplace of ideas and and definitely
pushing
what you believe i i respect somebody
that i feel is wrong as long as they
have conviction of what they say
and and that's what bitcoins do you keep
using the phrase marketplace of ideas
and then in the same interview it
reminded me
uh he says that we should seek
marketplace of ideas
not a marketplace of an idea
and the s on the end of ideas is really
important right that's very important
because the uh the the and he's talking
specifically about kind of
legacy or corporate media and he's
talking about look there is no
marketplace of ideas with an s
right it's just there's one idea that is
what everyone is supposed to cover
write talk about and if you stray from
that then literally
you are shunned from the community and i
think that
the what makes bitcoin so unique is that
there's argument
all day long and some of it is just
completely
entertainment purposes only especially
social media i mean you got people with
you know
cat logos and moon moon boys and
whatever with the lambos
yeah so you don't have a profile pic but
yeah it's all funny games to me i mean
that's why i like conferences
so we can see people in person and then
people can argue that's why even uh on
my show
a daily show gentlemen of crypto we have
[ __ ] bitcoin fridays
so you can show up in person and tell us
why you don't like bitcoin or why you
disagree with something we said what do
people say
i mean people love it i mean it's
something that would like show up and
actually say like well real stuff we
only had about two arguments
but most people come on and they argue
what other people are saying like yeah
this is trash or this sucks
but most people uh the arguments we've
had they have been
entertaining because most of them don't
know what they're talking about but yeah
it's great and like you said on social
media you see it you see the
disagreements what is just good
good exercise one of the arguments
recently that's been fascinating to
watch is this whole idea of
marathon the mining business
that uh up until literally today
they've basically said two things one
they were going to mine these ofac
compliant blocks right which basically
meant they were going to censor some
transactions
uh and then two was uh the upgrade
of new software they essentially were
refusing
to accept that upgrade or to participate
on purpose
yeah yeah very intentional um and so
today came out new ceo
uh over the last 30 days uh fred teal
and he basically just said look
we're gonna accept the upgrade we're not
gonna censor transactions like all the
things that i think the community
thought they should have done from day
one
to their credit they listened their
acting all that uh but i think it's a
perfect example
of there was arguing and and you could
say all you want that like the bitcoins
were going after somebody
but ultimately it meant that they had to
bend to the will of the community to the
social consensus right so do you think
that's a good thing
or is that is there a better way to get
that result without uh maybe some of the
toxicity or
uh uh the arguing or whatever you want
to talk actually no i think um
i agree with you i wish it was a better
way but this is how we are as humans if
you have some toxic you have some good
conversations whatever the the
the pot of stew is you put it together
and we come up with something good and i
think um
you know with their decision coming out
later that pressure
is because of consensus again we have a
consensus mechanism built into
the money so of course with the people
our consensus uh is a part of that so i
think we have pressured a lot of people
to
basically change their minds i mean
think about it we got banks to
capitulate
we can convince anybody we shamed
mark cuban into liking bitcoin because
he said it was bananas like and he's a
billionaire
you got 17 year old teenagers talking
about him on social media so
i mean yes there are some you know
different things people don't like but
overall i mean there's some very really
smart people we need all of it i think
and i think
again freedom of speech is number one i
i i really really like mark i think he's
incredibly intelligent
and um the thing i respect the most
about him is he goes and he does the
work
right so like there's a point where he
was like all this is nonsense you guys
are all idiots
whatever and then literally like i don't
know six weeks later i saw him on a
podcast
and he literally sounded smarter about
all the and not just like at a high
level right i'm talking about like
very very um kind of in the weeds
application specific stuff
and i said this guy went and did a crash
course he went and did the work and he
came out the other side and he changed
his mind
and also you have to respect the fact
that he changed his mind right with
percentage of new information all that
everybody gets it when they get it but
with all that said
one of the funniest moments i've seen
over the last two years is uh
he tweeted something early on before the
conversion yeah
and uh someone anonymous or pseudonymous
account on twitter literally said have
fun staying poor
and i literally was saying to myself
wait a minute there is literally a
pseudonymous account telling a
billionaire to have fun staying bored
and that's what i like about us i mean
even if it doesn't make sense
we just we stick we stick to our guns
it's more about the ethos right
it was more about the message it was
delivered exactly than it was about yeah
and i'm sure accuracy yeah and i'm sure
it got his attention just like it has
other people i mean
they can say they don't have that social
pressure but when you're on social media
a lot and you start seeing it from a
bunch of accounts
and again anonymous pseudo-anonymous
account
he's mark cuban he can just ignore it
but it's hitting him somewhere because
he did the work he learned about bitcoin
he's accepting dogecoin
i think he invested in uh what was that
polygon or something uh
yeah recently so he's doing the work so
you can only
meet people where they are and once they
get it they get it if not
hey bitcoin is they'll figure it out i
know somebody who
uh used to work with i don't think they
still work with them maybe they do move
they don't um
in an investing capacity and uh this is
maybe five six years ago
uh and he was really focused on
artificial intelligence i remember
asking like
what is he doing to kind of learn about
it i'm like oh you don't know this guy
does
he literally is going and getting the
academic papers he's going and getting
the actual
technology and he's reading books like
you know introduction artificial
like he's going to understand it better
than the founders who are pitching them
within a couple of weeks
and it feels like that's what he did on
crypto that's right when he did the work
and now all of a sudden he's very very
intelligent when people come and ask him
about stuff oh yeah absolutely that
keeps you ahead
because again you don't have to pay
those people now now you learn it i got
my own money
and he went out and did it kudos to him
yeah what do you think about laser eyes
oh man it's it's funny i have mixed
feelings because i started with laser
eyes but then i was like
i want to get them after 100k like
people was like laser race 200k it's
cool but i was like well that'd be cool
but i want to get it after 100k until
we go to a million hundred million
because i think that's the tipping point
of
everybody who has this environmental
debate or anything about the price or it
dipping
100k is the end of it forever i mean you
can't can't argue it so
i think it should be over already but uh
but 100k is the end of it and then we
can laser raise until the end of our
days
so so you think 100k that that specific
price point has
psychological like a psychological
impact explain that more um so i think
for one thing when we saw 10 000 as you
know i remember early in bitcoin 2013
14 when i started um 10 000 i was like
that is
we're rich if we get the ten thousand so
um i think that was for early adopters
and i think the new wave
which are millions of people way more
people them seeing bitcoin at his
all-time high 2017
hitting that point because a lot of
people bought the top they just saw it
on the news foam mode into it
and now they're in profit but seeing a
hundred thousand it basically gets rid
of the
if you buy it at some point um losing
money it's like just hold it like we
have even stronger holders
and i think i saw stanley drunken miller
say 86 percent of people that bought the
top did not sell
in 2017. so they're getting stronger so
i think that's a wild stat right
the specific thing he said was uh he
wasn't into bitcoin crypto any of this
stuff
paul tudor jones called him up and said
said stan
they're from what i understand very good
friends talk almost daily all stuff
uh and paul tudor jones said to him uh
of the people who bought bitcoin at
seventeen thousand dollars
eighty-six percent held it as it dropped
from seventeen thousand to three
thousand yep
stanley jackman was like who the hell
hold something from
thousand down to three thousand exactly
and fall through just like exactly
they're not selling not selling they're
not selling exactly
and uh and he cited that uh recently as
one of the reasons why he started to
actually become
more uh i don't even know sympathetic is
probably not the right word just just
more interested in it yeah right and
doing the work like you said and i think
that is a big uh proponent and then
psychologically again we passed 100k
i mean man it's it's pretty much over
and then at that point i think it's just
accepted
i think we're almost there it's just
this last dip kind of scared people out
but we we're not worried about people
with
lettuce hands like dave portnoy yeah
yeah whatever he sold at the first sign
of trouble i would hear but
he came back again like we said people
learn later they get it but again
there's some people that are still new
they'll learn they'll hold and then
they'll become you know the future
holders they'll be telling the class of
2022 and whoever
the same thing but i think 100k
psychologically that's that's the point
forget for a second the uh the substance
of the content
the reason why i love dave is did you
see the video where he picked a [ __ ]
coin
and he did it like a like a college yeah
college selection yeah what was the safe
moon he chose yeah come on dave
how much you're paying are you man
forget for a second the the
coins he's picking all this stuff but
just the idea that i'm going to go and
i'm going to treat it like a college
selection
video i mean he's he's creative but come
on man
then his choice video his choice was
safe moon and i was like jesus christ
what is going on but
i want to ask too did you see soulja boy
did the same thing with this promotion
what did he do
shout out to soldier boy love your stuff
but he
accidentally tweeted out the email of
how much he got paid oh i did see
he copy and pasted it right come on not
this is like 2017 again ico day so i'm
like come on but do you think it was how
abby soldier boy i got you man i'll help
you do what you got to do
uh but yeah i mean it's just you think
it is
no i don't think so i think he may have
just did it quickly like maybe on his
phone i don't know
but if it was it was genius because he
got him more because he got more and got
more hit right
so um and plus i thought the price was
low i was like twenty four thousand
he got twenty four thousand dollars if
they got two hundred and forty thousand
uh uh yeah something like that i don't
yeah but uh either way it's just this
has been going on since the mca few days
nothing new um but it's just you know i
flew down to the bahamas and went on
john mcafee's boat
no no i didn't know that you went to go
talk to him or just hang out like no i
wouldn't i record a podcast that's what
i was gonna say yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
i flew to uh bahamas he told me where he
was
and i brought my brother with me which
and we went on his boat and uh he got
hammered he was having time of his life
that's right uh and uh it was the
craziest
experience because this guy had guns
every i mean everywhere
and at the end we did a whole interview
i put up on youtube you watch it you're
like i got to watch it
whoa but at the very end he says me dude
you want to take a picture
i said sure man and so he goes all right
come on with me we go up on the back of
the boat uh
up top and uh he's got like a shotgun
he's got a rifle he's got all this stuff
he goes here you take this away
and he said to me he said uh oh yeah
your followers wouldn't like if you were
holding the gun i said no i'm pretty
sure they're cooling me holding the gun
i don't want to hold your gun
amen i love you john but hey i don't
know exactly what you've been through
brother
um look when i was hanging out with him
i'll tell you this though and it's very
fascinating right
yeah when you see somebody like that
what you realize is my biggest takeaway
when i left is everyone thinks this
guy's crazy this guy's
smarter he's way more intelligent than
people think he is right
we interviewed him as well did you guys
he was drinking his whole bottle of wine
the whole interview he started from when
he started i think college
all the way up to like all his career i
mean again fascinating man
super super smart i mean i think his
antics get
you know i mean that's that's what
people like to see but again intelligent
very smart man and i don't know what
he's doing now as far as with the case
is he locked up i think he got arrested
he got arrested yeah well he was on the
boat when we talked to himself yeah yeah
i think as long as he stayed on the boat
he was cool and then he got off he got
off somewhere they got him exactly
and it wasn't in the u.s but they still
got him um all right so you recently
posted this video
uh of the banks and uh absolutely
hysterical
right so you basically filmed individual
banks like the bit like the physical
buildings here in miami yep and then you
were like
yo jb morgan remember when you got fined
you know 900 million dollars or whatever
for gold and silver market manipulation
hey you know hsbc what about the cartel
uh
how much did you get find there and you
just went bank by bank by bank my bank
why does nobody else talk about this
like why is it that when we see you do
something like that everyone's like oh
wow like yeah that's like super
compelling
why doesn't the media cover it that way
um because that's
who pays their salary we all work for
somebody i mean we're all adults here
and you can't talk bad about the people
that
fund the politicians on your show it is
what it is but at the end of the day
the bitcoin ethos was started out as
competition or as
opposition to the banks because of what
they've done historically and it was
just
pointing out things that are very easily
googleable if that's
if that's a term just use google you can
see it for yourself um
and the things that they've done
especially with writing bitcoin in black
america
in my community i need people to realize
that these people
are do not have your best intentions
their business they do what they do
they get off with it sometimes they pay
fines whatever that's their business
but when you know that and you know
there's a better money system why would
you not use that so
i was just pointing that out and again
i'm not good at tick tock it took me
like 45 minutes to do it
it's very good videos like 40 seconds
and shout out to my wife for helping me
or fiance i should say soon to be wife
for helping me because i don't i don't
know how to use the new stuff i feel
like old man
i'm doing that tick tock but uh yeah it
came out okay how are you i think 32
you're 30 all right so you're same age
as i am
exactly and uh i went on tick tock one
time
and i could not figure out how to use it
in terms of creating content and so then
i said i'm just going to be a consumer
on this one
this is my third download i've deleted
it twice because i tried and i was like
jesus christ i can't i don't i mean it's
so much stuff
but i guess once you sit down and you
have you know your time with it i was
like i'll try it
you know shout out to my social media
manager ashley she has convinced me to
do it she was like you know just try it
see what happens
it's working like it's working i mean
that just came out this morning and
that's
i think the most engagement i've got on
twitter in a while so
uh i mean the biggest thing it's not
about social media but the information
people need to know this because then
people dig deeper and that's what i want
just how important
take the right message but put it into
the right kind of medium at this point
right so like you could have just
typed that up on twitter but it's the
fact that like it was done in a creative
way that's really what actually makes
the message kind of go viral oh yeah
well the biggest thing i think now is
kids i think people need to realize no
child under the age of 12
almost 13 now has lived in the world
without bitcoin so if they're on tick
tock
that's where we have to meet people
where they are and people say it all the
time in our community but
if they don't realize that kids are the
ones that realize gamification
um the ability to send digital money
they live in a digital world they
understand this stuff
that's what i'm focusing on so if tic
tac is the way that's the way
if teaching a summer camp this summer
which i am doing that's the way
because this next generation needs to
understand how important this is
so they grow up with it they're going to
be even more hardened than we are i mean
we're we're basically setting the stage
for them to come along so doing that
that's the reason why man
what is summer camp uh the summer camp
the bitcoin summer camp will be in
charlotte north carolina first time ever
in charlotte
um with innovative learning uh it's a
501c3 after school
and summer camp and bitcoin will be a
part of it july the first monday of
every july
of july first week um so anybody that
wants to sign up sign up start uh in two
weeks
uh we we have partnered with big give to
raise money
shout out to everybody who has donated
and we want to keep it going because
there's also a crypto kids camp in
inglewood
uh with nigel roberts uh she had the
very first one
we're doing it on the east coast she's
on the west coast so trying to get that
going because again we see the
importance of kids
learning this information how old are
the kids that'll go to this uh grades 6
through 10
at my camp at hurricane i believe grades
5 through 10.
okay so grades 6 through 10 most of
these kids don't know anything about
economics money
finance any of this stuff and in some
way if you can teach them about it
before
kind of the system gets to them you
don't have to teach them to unlearn
things you can just teach them to learn
right from scratch oh yeah and and my
mom is a teacher
grandmother's a teacher i'm a former
teacher we've seen the public school
education system they don't teach you
finances
they don't teach you about balancing any
any type of account bitcoin does all of
that teaches you the history of money
you go down the river hold technology
all these things are important and i
think that
starting early it gets ingrained in them
that this is what's coming anyway so
we might as well start now because we
didn't have that during the internet age
i remember
we thought of it as like an option to
learn the code which we really should
have took it serious because we could
have built some of the facebooks or
google's
but that is you know it is what it is
we're trying to change that now
i think the first time you came on the
podcast maybe a year and a half two
years ago
yes right uh how has the receptiveness
or the understanding of bitcoin in the
black communities across america changed
so far
is there progress oh absolutely i think
um you know
it's funny price drives everything yeah
so price goes up a lot of people believe
you
but also too i mean it's just it is what
it is um because a lot of people this is
their first time investing
so they they need to see the win on the
money side but they also understand
um that there's something wrong with our
economy i mean the fact that we printed
so much money i believe 25
of our total supply just in the last six
months i mean jesus christ how how much
more can we print
inflation is increasing and having that
second option
is viable and then kovid was like i mean
that shocked all of us
that was a black swan event within a
black swan event a bitcoin
we didn't see that but once it happened
i think that's what got people to
understand
maybe there's a different way bitcoin
may work you know cryptocurrencies
you know whoever wants to deal with them
that could work as well but um
i think long term people understand
what's coming
so it got easier uh you know to explain
and i think the pushback kind of stopped
i haven't had much pushback only a few
people who
haven't even read the white paper or
people that don't know but most people
are like i'll at least learn a little
bit
uh to get it started especially with you
know billionaires getting
involved unfortunately i mean i've been
talking about eight years but
they need to see that and then yeah it
feels like um
another driving factor here is uh
there's a whole bunch of studies that
show the bottom 45
of americans who happen to usually live
in inner cities who are minorities
all this stuff right that we just know
the deck is stacked against
a lot of folks in these communities uh
the bottom 45 percent
experience inflation way more
drastically than the top 40
right yes and it's just merely uh simple
things like hey if you've got a bunch of
investable assets versus not
of course the person that doesn't have
investment assets you're gonna have a
hard time with inflation
other things around the percentage of
let's say
food in terms of uh your overall monthly
spending
right so if you're super wealthy and you
get a bunch of investments the amount
that you spend on food's probably
actually not that high compared to
somebody who literally
you know 25 40 of their paycheck every
month goes towards food right to feed
their family and so i started to look at
uh some of the data and the two data
points that just have
kind of shocked me are uh tyson foods
which one
you know 30 billion food supplier uh in
q1 they reported the
average increase of their products
from a price standpoint seven and a half
percent wow
30 billion dollar food supplier saying
the average increase of our goods
that we sell we have increased prices on
an average by 75
wow and so that's not every food right
that's not there
but like that's one really big food
supply big food supply
even commodities you see commodities
going up i see people making jokes about
selling wood
behind in the alley because this is what
400 percent
yeah you can't find it and i think those
indicators were inflation as well like
you just said yep with the food
the second one around the food is there
was a study that good morning america
so the reason why good morning america
is interesting to me is one that's a
mainstream audience
that's not a finance economics right uh
wall street type audience
uh and then three is they looked at year
over year change and so what they said
was
uh from grocery stores food prices are
up two and a half percent
from april 2020 to april 2021.
now whether it's right or wrong
that two and a half percent way higher
than a quote unquote official cpi
inflation number exactly
and so it's again even if it's not two
and a half it's two percent or it's
three percent i still have still higher
than the official numbers
right and so you start to look at okay
that
sounds like you're pushing people to go
learn about how do i protect my dollars
because literally if i'm sitting in
dollars everything's getting more
expensive around me
but i'm sitting in this other asset
bitcoin everything's getting cheaper
around me
oh yeah yeah right i mean it's just
simple math i mean
over time compound annual growth as we
know over 200
we know over time the longer you hold
bitcoin more purchasing power
and again it's funny for starting out i
used to always say it was always either
rich people that got bitcoin
or that didn't care or it was poor
people like myself who had nothing to
lose
and i think we're convening now at this
point where it's like well
we both need to use it because all of
our dollars are are at stake right now
because of inflation so you're right i
think those numbers are
they're probably lying i mean i just i
think most people are lying
uh just to keep you have to keep the
sheep calm man you gotta make sure
nobody goes crazy
at a certain point that's gonna break
and i think that sounded crazy
until last year happened yeah right if
you came here and you were like oh
they're all lying everyone would be like
all right conspiracy theorists like go
sit in the corner be quiet
the conspiracy theorists are more right
than the mainstream media
i mean it's amazing conspiracy theories
literally are just a few years
too early that's it that's all
conspiracy theorists are now because it
seems like everything's coming out
as the truth and i mean i don't believe
everything but a lot of it is just
research and data and we see that like
there's no way
we're okay right now we have zero
percent interest rates on houses what
happened the last time we had that
i mean come on man you can't you can't
hide it it's good money supply you know
how they say
graphs charts don't go in a straight
line apparently it does our money supply
literally went into this
rocket ship i mean there was no it's
about to the moon then what money
supplies to the moon i mean jesus christ
i mean all that money being printed and
and all of the the data we have like you
just presented
uh i mean you'd be a fool to not think
something's not going on
yeah what's up guys before we continue
with this interview i want to quickly
talk about our sponsor
kraken kraken's one of the most
established and secure places to buy
cryptocurrencies on the internet
they've been at the forefront of the
bitcoin and blockchain revolution for
over 10
years their mission is to bring crypto
to the masses
so whether you're an og or this is your
first trade
kraken has all of the tools that you
need to achieve financial freedom
with more than 60 cryptocurrencies
available you can invest in
all of the most popular projects in the
industry including bitcoin ethereum
and many many more kraken also provides
in-depth articles
and guides on every single asset that
they list so you can get up to speed
quickly and make smarter investment
decisions
visit kraken.com bang bang to get
started today
again that's kraken.com bang bang all
right let's get back into this interview
i hope you're enjoying it how important
is it
especially for the black community when
you see like nas and jay-z they put out
a new song
now it's talking about uh coinbase
talking about being the cryptocurrency
scarface like he's got a couple of
different lines that are in there
that reference investing cryptocurrency
all this stuff
uh jay-z right a couple of times talking
about being a billionaire and then his
wife being a billionaire and also like
how much impact does that have it has to
be something that people look up to it's
aspirational and they're like
oh well it's good enough for them then i
should be learning about this stuff as
well
oh yeah absolutely and uh you know jay-z
also started a fun with jack dorsey
500 bitcoin i believe fund and ghana um
so he's definitely putting his money
where his mouth is now he's early
investing in coinbase
amazing stuff and i think that helps
with people who are not
uh regular investors because they use
they use uh basically the media and and
musicians to get messages out
but once they're in there they can learn
from people like us because they'll look
for the experts and things of that
nature so
i thank them for their help i have joked
before it is kind of funny that we look
at
musicians for financial advice uh you
know especially in the black community
and i kind of joked about that saying
hey i don't really see the white
community
uh looking at eminem for financial
advice but uh
at the end of the day all roads lead to
bitcoin and all roads lead to
financial security how many black
billionaires
are outside of the media
well yeah let's say entertainment and
sports yeah
um oprah's the most famous okay but
she's a radio
i believe she's the richest okay and but
that's still media technical media slash
business yeah right like she owned the
network she owned a bunch of stuff
like she got stuff um and i would say
robert smith uh
right yep um he's yeah we're four
billion it's not many
um and but it doesn't have to be
billionaires multi millionaires
millionaires
businesses they don't get on tv much you
don't see them they don't have the
flashy stuff
and i think that's pushed more than the
average you know businessman or high you
know ceo that has
a business going but hopefully that can
change the reason why i say that is
because actually if you think about
most of the billionaires that if you
said to me right now name you know
name five black billionaires right the
ones that come immediately
to mind are kanye west jay-z
right uh beyonce lebron's probably there
it's not already there right i mean you
start to go down this list and you're
like wait a second
these are people who not only have built
a billion plus dollar fortune
right you can say whatever you want
about them i don't care you can say
kanye west is crazy and i'll tell you
yeah but he's got six and a half billion
dollars and you don't yeah
crazy billionaire he figured it out by
the way
have you seen richard branson because
that's basically a white kanye west
right he's
doing crazy [ __ ] too exactly he just
can't make a beat
[Laughter]
people don't know of as much but but
that is uh to some degree it's like the
people who don't do what the normal
person does
they get the non-normal result exactly
right and
by the way that can work in positive or
negative ways right but you just get the
outlier result if you
take the outlier action yeah but what's
fascinating to me is
kanye jz like these people with the big
platforms who are
coming from music or entertainment yep
they're starting to talk about it
yeah and they're not starting to talk
about it from like uh you know if you go
back and listen to some of jc's early
music right
it was more about you know flipping a
brick of drugs on the street
right because that's what he knew now
all of a sudden he's talking about
buying buildings and
art and being a billionaire and all
reinvesting and all yeah it completely
changes the conversation i think and so
it's just
fascinating to to see this happen and
then you layer in now also they're
getting into cryptocurrency right he's
becoming cool
tom brady like all these different
people start to capitulate and join
floyd mayweather do you think he's got
bitcoin
i think he does um if not him his
financial manager has to have a little
bit
do you think he knows anything about
bitcoin not particularly uh he i don't
think he's read the white paper but i
think he knows how it works
the number go up that's how most people
view it and then later they'll say oh
yeah this is
you know yeah yeah the best who do you
think has more bitcoin 50 cent or floyd
maybe definitely 50 cent
uh he sold the album for bitcoin i think
yeah but he said he sold bitcoin
yeah but i mean he probably but but he
saw that the magic government was like
well let me get a little bit more i mean
probably 50 cent um but yeah i think
they have a substantial amount
that that is still one of the greatest
all-time beefs on the internet
is when when uh 50 cent challenge floyd
mayweather read a book and then jimmy
kimmel will say you come do it on my
show
oh man that was hilarious i mean 50 cent
is the king of beasts i mean
he does i mean he's hilarious and he'll
challenge you to a fight i mean
can't really beat 50 cent i think you
actually got to fight with floyd
mayweather
like it's like a scuffle i don't know
yeah but i mean that's like friend stuff
so yeah
i mean it is what it is 50 cent i follow
him on instagram and everyone smile
he'll post a random photo of somebody
and
it's not obviously not a very uh
flattering photo right
and i i don't have the context behind
what the beef is and
and then all of a sudden he uh i forget
what the hashtags he uses on
but he's something like he doesn't
forget like just you know you just
realize like hey
dude i'm not messing with this guy right
right she'll leave 50 sit alone man
you'll be all right
what's this story with sheets i saw you
oh yeah
she started accepting bitcoin and then
you were like yo i told like was like a
regional manager about it or something
yeah
yeah so no it was interesting because
during covet i left l.a
uh went to be with my fiance in virginia
where she was at and i had a few
people uh with brick and mortar stories
that was setting up bitcoin atm so i'm
setting up bitcoin atms all through
kovitt
you know most people are you know
sitting inside i was outside i was like
i'm sorry i was like 50 cent get
richard.trying i was like i'm sorry
i got to make this money i got a
daughter on the way so i was out here
and i was in
the sheets and i'd asked the people who
worked there a few times about a big one
atm
but they didn't know what i was talking
about one day regional manager just
happened to be there i guess you know
doing paperwork whatever and i mentioned
it to him and i said matter of fact you
all should accept bitcoin and he kind of
was thinking he was like
but i don't know what that is he's just
like i get it like i'm trying to explain
it to him uh i don't even know how he
listened to him but i was like yeah you
all can earn money for just having an
atm and
people can't accept it now did that turn
into them accepting it i don't know
but the biggest thing is me telling him
i'm pretty sure that's one of the first
times he heard it and maybe their
company their research but
who knows that was a you know but if
there's one thing ten other people do
the same thing
right it increases the probability i
probably sold two other sheets but i was
the only one
i saw the regional manager but i mean
again i've gotten gas stations in la
to get a bitcoin atms and to accept
bitcoin so it was how does that work
when you go and you install an atm they
get just paid like a percentage
or a flat fee yeah so uh different
companies but one i know for sure
coinflip
they'll pay the brick and mortar to
house it there they'll pay you rent
and you don't have to deal with the
upkeep so if you have a brick and mortar
store you can do that right now
if you refer a brick and mortar store
they'll pay you as a referral
um but just helping people do that the
reason i was doing it was more for the
community
i realize in the black community a lot
of people have cash they have money in
the mattress
they can't always get straight on the
exchange i think cash app has solved a
little bit of that problem
new exchanges made it a little easier
but atms facilitate the
ability for them to get it quicker and
uh i think when stores do it or have it
as well
in a local place that helps them on
board the bitcoin so that's really why i
was doing it
you know did what i had to do but she's
doing it that's great um
the everybody's gonna capitulate at some
point so it's better to just do it
earlier they have the infrastructure
coinstar same thing sent them email 2014
15. why can't i not put this change
because i was so poor i support change
and that'll be gas money like 30
worth why can't i turn that into bitcoin
and then four years later
you can do it and i was like i don't
know if it came from me but i'm pretty
sure i was the first person to mention
it but it happens i mean
again again they hear it from one two
three five ten twenty three start
somewhere
we should pay attention exactly yeah but
everybody capitulates so it's all good
bitcoin wins at the end true uh
another thing that is winning is bitcoin
black billionaires oh yeah
what is this one two how the hell do you
have a hundred thousand people in your
clubhouse
hey man um shout out to lamar wilson uh
co-founder
uh he came to me with the idea it's
bitcoin black billionaires or black
people like bitcoin
okay black bitcoin billionaires one
clubhouse and um
what happened was a lot of bees man
there's a lot of people there's only one
other triple b i know
and that was a clothing brand that went
up and maybe that was so hot i know
we had a new triple b alliteration works
that's all i got to say
but black bitcoin billionaires
absolutely on clubhouse new app
in december kind of started you know
getting popular lamar called me he said
you know we've worked together before he
said why don't we start a group teach
white people about bitcoin you know
the price is going up it's a you know we
gotta have a sense of urgency we started
it
and i think we've had uh let's see ten
different um
channels basically so we have uh the
genesis block on monday we have uh
bitcoin office hours
we have uh granny krypto who teaches to
older people who we have
i mean it's it's so many what was the
last one great granny crypto oh granny
crypto
yep and she teaches as well i mean we
have moderators that teach different
classes
uh club cuevo on saturdays keep it fun
and light more like entertainment and i
think getting people who shows up
no it's one of our friends he's in miami
uh
but yeah he sounds like somebody need to
go out with on friday night
yeah he has the lambo he's cool guy and
again part of the black bitcoin
billionaires
is all aspects education entertainment
you know lifestyle how things go
and uh the best part was we teamed up
with cash out we were able to give away
a million satoshi's
to thousands of people and we were able
to give it away for free
teach people about it and we also have
who wants to be a satoshi millionaire on
thursdays
so people can come and earn satoshi's uh
thank you cash out for that also some of
our other sponsors but it's great
because
we're giving people exactly what they
want without them necessarily having to
buy it
education and the start get some skin in
the game so black bitcoin billionaires
is you know pretty much
blown up and out here in miami we have a
lot of events that we're doing now
because of that
what are you guys going to do for the
conference oh yeah so for the conference
uh we have the bitcoin classic the first
bitcoin tournament
that rewards the winners in bitcoin uh
it's a basketball tournament basketball
are you good at basketball
very uh oh but not anymore but not
anymore like i used to
because again all right so either good
or you're not good oh right now i'm
still
one of the best shooters out all right
but everything else man
i'm 32 giving it away but uh but as far
as shooting i mean i always tell people
this story and i hate saying it because
nobody believes me but yes
when me and steph curry played at his
dad's summer camp with dale curry i beat
him and his dad in a three-point contest
i don't really i don't know how many
people have beat him in real life but i
know for sure i got the shirt to sign it
and i signed everything i got the
picture and everything to prove it but
yes
so so you're saying you're better than
steph curry i was at one point no
what about now no absolutely not he's
the best point guard of all time nobody
of all time
yeah i think so all right not anymore i
stopped playing once i
you know hurt my knee all right so uh
the other thing is
if you are running the basketball
tournament you're also going to do this
uh mansion party yeah so we got the
mansion party
um june 5th it'll be three to eight uh
we also three to eight
mm-hmm from three in the afternoon until
eight p.m oh yeah we partying for a
little bit brother
what are you guys gonna do for five
hours in the middle of the afternoon
networking you know we got a pool there
and then uh it's a lot mansion party and
networking are on two ends of the
spectrum look
we're gonna try and fuse it together
just like education entertainment we're
gonna put them together
and uh try and get a lot of people in
one spot because a lot of people want to
meet the moderators or meet each other
so
and i can only imagine the traffic um
because again
mayweather is here so um we definitely
want to have that and then
we'll have a community event sunday uh
it'll be in little haiti
we'll actually be giving away free books
we'll be in the park and we'll also be
having a um
a cookout i'm sorry june 5th with um
nigel roberts and hill harper they have
one we'll kind of go over there some of
us
uh for the black uh wall street app
which is out today so
we'll i mean we have a lot of events
actually i think this is the most black
people at any bitcoin event ever
really i i believe so as far as tickets
from spectators and people that are
coming to the events
i believe so which is a big thing for me
because i used to be the only black
person at events and i was like we need
this more than anybody why are you not
around yeah and it's not about you know
not against other people it's really
about every group is going to have to
join in order for it to be mainstream
so you might as well bring them to the
conferences let them see how it works
and i think this is a good example
is there safety in numbers like in terms
of the more people you see if you go to
a conference there's five thousand
people
right i don't care if they're black
white green purple whatever
but then you go to another conference
twelve thousand people all of a sudden
you
feel like oh there's twelve thousand
other people here like i must be on to
something yeah
right exactly versus if there's a
conference with 20 people you're like
okay my
am i a nerd right now yeah i've been to
those two
i mean i've been i've been to enough
conferences now where it's like this is
amazing 12 000 people
there's nothing to sniff at that's you
know nfl game i mean that's that's
you know a small college game like
that's pretty good as far as the amount
of people but also the impact we can
have
if we actually try i know some people
here come in to flash with each other
and eat dinner and laugh but
me being in the streets working with
people the real people who need it i've
been doing that my whole
basically career of learning about
bitcoin so it feels familiar and being
able to do that is gonna be great
yeah that's awesome um talk about the
wall street it's black wall street
digital wallet
well the black wall street app and it is
a digital wallet but
yep and it drops today may 31st um
and it's in uh celebration of the black
wall street in tulsa oklahoma dating
back to 1921 100 year anniversary
so 100 years since then explain just
real high level what is black wall
street what was the event in tulsa for
those that don't know
absolutely so there were many black wall
streets around the country as they were
referred to
um basically it was a mostly black
community where they had libraries they
had you know
ceos they had airplanes they had a
built-up community
that was prosperous because they
circulated their dollars and they were
free to work
however because of some of the policemen
and white men that were around that were
jealous
burned into the ground killing hundreds
of people i believe there's only a
couple survivors left
now that was something they actually
built it up later but it was never
really the same
and in other places the same thing
happened florida georgia
all over the place um and wilmington
north carolina
all these places had economic growth in
black communities that were burned to
the ground by people who were either
jealous
or didn't want to economically let them
get forward so in celebration of that
uh 100 years later what we're doing is
building a digital black wall street
because as i've said before
you can't burn down bitcoin and the the
best part about this
this whole movement is that because it
is global we have the backing of people
from everywhere
not just a small brick and mortar
community that can be tainted so i'm
glad hill harper and nigel roberts have
introduced that
helping consult with that with lamar and
other people they have a great tech team
and i think it's going to take off
because
again they have they have the ability to
dollar cost averaging a bitcoin as well
as have a digital wallet
which i think bodes well for the future
why does the tulsa oklahoma one get so
much attention compared to the other
ones i didn't know that there was other
situations where this had occurred so
why does that one get
i think it was a lot of the attention i
think was considered the most prosperous
okay of all those kind of the biggest
it's kind of the biggest one yep
absolutely and because
they did have so much commerce matter of
fact it was so heinous when it happened
that they showed it as opening scene on
watchmen
uh and people thought it was fake they
were like why would you show all of this
murder and all this stuff they were like
this really happened that's how crazy it
was so
we can only um really you know celebrate
our ancestors by doing something
economically
because since that time nothing has
really worked right so i think
economically taking that step
i'm sorry it took 100 years but shout
out to the ancestors that built that
time we're doing that now in 2021.
you were the person who turned me onto
the whole idea of uh
when a system is stacked against its
people yeah right uh just as a
population in general not nothing to do
with the color someone's skin the only
way to fight back
is through technology uh which i think
most people okay they understand that
but specifically the black community's
relationship with money banks
the financial system the censorship
resistance
becomes incredibly important the
decentralization of all of this
becomes the most important thing
right which is ultimately what bitcoin
is going after
but once you start to educate people it
almost becomes the default right in that
why would i go
and use a system that i know is stacked
against me when i have a system that
when i want a loan it just says i don't
care who you are i don't even know your
name just you got the assets or not
exactly completely different way of
thinking about it right compared to the
legacy system where it's come in
where do you work how much money is in
your bank account you know yeah well
address a certain way you gotta
yeah dude send me your electrical bill i
need all this like nonsense
yeah and i mean even then you still
might get denied for a loan or if you
get it pay higher rates because there
are banks that have paid
those fees in lawsuits uh because
they've given higher rates to black and
brown people for the same
qualifications just based off of what i
don't know zip code or how they look or
who knows
um but you're right uh we we owe them no
allegiance and
in hindsight i think in the next few
years in hindsight it's going to make
perfect sense that we moved to bitcoin
like i feel bad for people who just kind
of push it away completely
uh your grandkids are probably going to
not respect you
like what did you do during the biggest
transfer wealth of all time oh well i
was on twitter
telling everybody not to buy it or that
was bad for the environment
uh those people that said that 99 about
amazon looks stupid on forbes i'm sorry
you look dumb now because who's talking
about amazon's environmental impact
right now nobody
same thing with bitcoin it's taking his
lumps it's taking his criticism but in
hindsight i think the black community
will realize
this is going to happen i mean
technology eats everything
and you're right it does solve a lot of
the racist stuff we saw like
black people not getting a taxi in new
york uber solved that now taxi drivers
are begging black people
please get in my taxi because they don't
have any business so it happens
uh it happens so true
that's what tech does and i think
bitcoin does that now
explain it more so there's a problem
with taxi drivers i've seen the signs in
the taxis
in new york city that basically says
it's a crime not to pick up somebody
based on the color of their skin
gender or whatever right so it was
obviously a problem probably enough
where
they would go when they would actually
put uh the signs in uber basically said
look you press a button they don't even
know who you are until they show up
exactly
and so that completely has all the
issues and tech that's technology
specifically addressing that issue
uh not intentionally not that's not why
uber was created right but it's a second
order effect of it
and so bitcoin essentially having a very
similar second order effect here right
bitcoin was created for just
a human but this ends up being a second
order benefit
absolutely and and decentralization is
on the scale right so uber's not
completely decentralized but it's more
decentralized than taxis are
and then you may get something more
decentralized than that in the future
whereas no central authority is
literally anybody can use it
you know and check through smart
contract you know however it moves but
yeah that's what they did and i think uh
again bitcoin would do the same thing
just as we as we've seen with other
technology
you've mentioned floyd mayweather
multiple times he's gonna headline and
put that in air quotes i don't really
know what that means
uh of the bitcoin conference good bad or
indifferent
floyd mayweather is the headline i think
it's good for publicity but
i'm kind of indifferent i mean again me
and you we've been to plenty of
conferences
who cares right i mean you're going to
talk when you talk if you need to put
him at the front
then that's fine as well he gets up
there he says what he has to say uh he
has a fight this weekend so
maybe just promotion is it a fight no
this is uh
this is a good good good payoff and uh
some good entertainment i mean i think
the best the best fight was when he took
his hat and he ran off
or whatever only
logan paul two of the greatest marketers
of our generation
very yeah i think they're moving up
there with the kris jenner
uh as far as marketing and media because
how they got this far out to fight
employment with i don't know but it's
logan going from a youtuber to that is i
mean
yeah i'll give you something even better
logan paul and look from everything i
understand
incredibly intelligent right incredibly
hard working
you have to be yeah very successful when
he puts his mind to doing something him
and his team
uh and also very creative from if you
look at
the various lines of business and all
that like so again very similar to what
i think people would say about like a
kris jenner and all that kind of stuff
but he's had two fights right i think he
lost one and he
had a tie yeah so
again zero disrespect at all right
because guess what if him and i got in a
uh into a ring he's like six inches
taller than me i think right
uh i stumbled his ass
but get the right punch you never know
yeah he gets in the ring with floyd
mayweather
like that is a skill to get floyd
mayweather to agree to this fight
marketing genius i mean if the money is
right that's one thing about money
in business if the money's right and
none of that other stuff matters it's
like well we can both do we know how
much they're all getting paid i don't
know the purse but didn't how much did
you make last time like 50 million
i don't know i don't know no jake paul
didn't make fun of jake paul 25 i don't
know but
no no my guess is that he made five to
ten which by which by the way
five to ten million dollars a lot of
money forever a fight how many people
fight for free i mean come on i think
ben ashton got a million dollars
yeah and and ben ben showed up like he
just finished drinking beers at the bar
no i think ben trained very hard for
this
yeah i love ben and dave i love you man
but i was like
he showed up for the money he just want
to get it he's like i can fight but i
don't really care about this dude i mean
this is whatever out of the whole
floyd screen's the smartest one yeah i i
think he was in the ring for 15 seconds
he's got his money i got partying to do
man give him a million dollars i'm out
of here i would have did it too
let me know when i get that contract
jake paul i'll jump in there for 15
seconds so how much
how much would it take you to fight jake
paul in the ring oh man
uh i'd say i'll take 10 million 10
million yeah but you wouldn't do it for
a million
no that's not enough okay at least ten
five to ten i was five to ten all right
i already knew i'm like don king
negotiations a lot longer than they did
to get it going
well i mean ben didn't train yeah but at
least he fought before you know what i
mean like
i just did you know i actually think ben
trained more than we think he did
but everyone expected him not to train
at all and therefore you know training
for
two hours a day was it was a stuff ben's
got crypto
or whatever he got the podcast he's
chilling man he's not really worried
about that
acres that's what he is
love you man hope to see you soon man
well yeah that was that was funny
because again marketing genius he got in
there
people watched it made money from it why
not yeah
it's so good uh do we think that logan
paul has any chance
no i don't know i think floyd may
stretch it out just for fun
but no i mean i think that logan no for
a reason i think that logan paul has
one opportunity if he gets off a
first round
right you're bigger you're stronger and
just
all out gas yourself maybe you get lucky
if it happens you're a legend
yeah you're a legend if it doesn't
happen you were gonna lose anyways and
just
okay everyone's gonna say damn you got
in the ring with a 15-0 you know world
champion he has no expectations so i
think that's his best
his best asset right now no expectations
no pressure why not
what happens if he knocks out fleming
weather oh man that would just confirm
that we're in the matrix
i mean i've it's been some weird [ __ ]
happening this last couple years
that's all i keep saying to myself i
wouldn't be surprised age of aquarius
people
and people are talking about end times
it's some weird [ __ ] that's been
happening last year i mean
if logan paul knocks out floyd
mayweather is it the greatest knockout
of all time
greatest has to be i mean i mean like
non-professional
and the maybe greatest of all time yes
you legitimately have to start asking
yourself like okay cool i kid ali and
frazier like all these different fights
like
logan paul first floyd mayweather logan
paul knocks him out might be it's top 10
knockouts no that's easy number one but
it's not gonna happen
floyd's gonna win easily you might
stretch it out have some fun
dance around a little bit yeah he's
going you can't hit him i mean
did you think that conor mcgregor had a
chance when they boxed i don't think he
had a chance either all right so i
actually thought conor mcgregor had more
of a chance than most people thought he
had
and i was pleasantly surprised by the
the uh
when he showed up how well he performed
he lost yeah right
he came out here i liked how he fought
him yeah he did try and actually box him
after like six rounds with the mcgregor
fight it was pretty obvious that hey
look he's not gonna win this because
he's got
tired out all this stuff and mayweather
is the you know one of if not the
greatest of all time
yeah uh that's what i say he's just
gotta try to knock him out in the first
round just literally come out
and just forget a three minute round i'm
gonna come out i got 30 seconds
that's it yeah come out swing it as hard
as you can because i mean again i think
floyd
he just he just suffers from lebron
james syndrome we get tired of seeing
greatness over and over so you try to
make up a reason in your head while
you're losing you think about like no
he's not gonna lose
but the best chance is that run at him
hard as you can maybe grab them a little
bit try and get some punches in there
but uh that's about it i don't after
that it's not landing
many punches on floyd good luck man i
mean
have fun but it's not happening i'm
sorry
i think he just needs the money yeah i
mean
how much do you think floyd's getting oh
floyd ain't stepping in the ring for
less than 50. that's what i said i said
at least 50 million and that's not a bad
thing if i can get in the fight with
the ring and fight a non-professional
for 50 million free dollars
hang out in miami for the weekend why
not yeah yeah i mean he
my guess is that 50 is the starting
number then he gets a piece of
stuff he stays relevant like all this
kind of stuff
uh mcgregor would he get 100 million
something like that yeah right so it's
just like you start to put the numbers
together you're like yeah man if you get
paid 100 million dollars to fight you
know conor mcgregor
you're not stepping in at 50 less
because i find a youtuber on the off
chance that he gets lucky with a shot
and knocks you out and your whole career
is defined by you knocked out by a
youtuber better get some big money off
of that because i hope he
i hope he gets money off the replays or
you know whoever
plays it after that because if that
happens man the residuals from that
everybody will just rewatch
that's part of it if i'm floyd
mayweather i'm negotiating the contract
i'm like look
i want my 50 million 100 million
whatever the number is and by the way if
there's a knockout i want to get paid
right everything from the yeah
literally you may be
but i mean again it's it's fun to talk
about but i am glad he has
a bitcoin conference because he was
messing with some [ __ ] coin before that
i don't know who
introduced him but there's a lot of them
in 2017. you know ti jamie foxx dj
khaled
i'm glad we got all that out the way
hopefully they can come talk to somebody
like myself or others
black bitcoin billionaires who can lead
them to the light because if they go
that way
then their message will resonate more
like with jay-z and us
russ okong right perfect
a bunch of these guys who are in that
same circle of athlete entertainer
musician right they get it mm-hmm oh
yeah and
lala anthony out there and entertainment
spencer then with you know
people that i've talked to that are you
know quote-unquote famous are getting it
now because
they saw the ico bubble they see sort of
the scams going away and they're like no
what's the real information and i think
we have a perfect time of doing that
right now
tom brady drastically underrated how
important it was that he capitulated and
jumped
oh yeah like a couple of these
professional athletes
that i've talked to have said oh
thompson
brady i mean he's a goat right no yeah
how are you not gonna listen to tom
brady now every time i bring up tom
brady i have to say that he's on two in
the super bowl against eli manning and
the new york giants of course but
other than that wouldn't expect anything
obviously i mean it was funny those were
the two that i literally was
sure they were going to win now both
lost and then i got lucky some of those
but this
was uh was it 08 no
whichever was the one where tyree caught
it on his helmet yeah it was 2012
or whatever when david tyree and they
brought and they broke the undefeated
undefeated season and that's when i was
like sure they were winning nope and
then the second time i was like they're
gonna get revenge you gotta get
nope i was like man that was i was wrong
on both of those i lost a little money
on that tom never bet against the new
york giants
and by the way the new york giants they
don't win the super bowl if they're good
and they don't win the super bowl if
they're bad
but if they go eight and eight in the
regular season watch maybe
they just i used to always say i feel
like they're saving themselves
because they're actually better than
this because they get to the playoffs
and they love running through people
to get to them but it's all good man in
saquon we trust okay
i'm making the comeback oh yeah all
right where can we send people to get
the book
summer camp and then anything you're
doing with the conference oh yeah so uh
the book bitcoinblackamerica.com
the summer camp it'll be posted on
givetrack.com you can follow
the progress there and then at the
conference i'll be speaking june 4th
uh at 110 speaking of what is a
bitcoiner which should be interesting
um and then after that i'll be around at
black bitcoin billionaires mansion
you can find it on black
bitcoinbillionaire.com black billionaire
black bitcoin billionaire black bitcoin
billionaire.com
all right uh before i let you go the
book you're on the second version
second version is on pre-order and it'll
be released this month absolutely okay
so the first one
people can go buy second version is it
just updated or it's a whole new
set of content seven new chapters and it
also includes audio book
it has the digital copy and three
webinars attached it's more of an
educational experience because people
need to learn
you know sense of urgency so if somebody
bought the first one they should
definitely still go by the cycle
absolutely
awesome take it a step up man you got to
start and then where can people find you
on twitter
at bitcoinsay and uh instagram the
isaiah jackson
yeah you got the tick tock out there now
that you're a tick tocker hey man i got
two tick tocks out baby it took me a
total of
an hour and a half but i'm getting it
i'm getting close
but uh hopefully because i've seen some
crypto tick tocks i would just
horrendous i'm like jesus christ these
people suck
you see that you see the guy who did the
scam token no no i haven't i mean i'm
not that dude i got four followers man
there's a guy who uh
he said something like uh watch this and
he and he created scam token and it was
like
secure computerized automatic
he just did some word salary whatever
yeah but it's called scam scam and he
put it together
and he was like read it out and he was
like scam
and then he like released it and uh
it had like i don't know seventy
thousand dollar market cap within
seconds he was like
y'all idiots out of buying everything
yeah
he's like i don't know what i just did i
just released a scam
yeah you just copy and paste somebody's
uh github those are them up there i'm
buying that smart chain
i've seen some terrible coins you can
probably get a 100 000 market cap in two
days
because it's like bots to just buy the
new stuff just in case
this is crazy but that's that's the
that's what we're in now
it's it's it's the wild west still
in certain aspects just like 2017 but
that's what bitcoin is for that's why i
love it
all right man listen we gotta do this
again thank you so much for coming oh
yeah oh yeah absolutely anytime man